the army in Lebanon has cleared all the
major roads in the capital Beirut and
other cities as anti-government protests
died down in the wake of Prime Minister
Saad Hariri s-- resignation on Tuesday
the Army had asked demonstrators earlier
on Wednesday to clear all roadblocks to
ensure that life returns to normal the
country sought 12 days of protests over
a weakening economy and corruption but
so far there been no protests on
Wednesday Hariri has been asked to
become caretaker Prime Minister until
the new government can be put into place
that's got lived' out of Beirut al
Jazeera Stephanie Decker is outside the
Prime Minister's residence in the
Capitol steps so the president has asked
the cabinet to stay on in a caretaker
capacity what happens next
yeah this is a line of the Constitution
the important things the big question
marks still going forward is now we're
waiting for the president announced what
they call binding parliament party
consultation so the heads of the
political bloc's in Parliament will be
discussing with the president as to who
they will appoint as a potential new
prime minister this in accordance with
the laws here needs to be a Sunni then
if there is agreement on that person
that person is then tasked with forming
a government and then that needs to be
agreed upon by the Parliament I've moved
it on by the part of it so there's a lot
up in the air we know there's a lot of
back-and-forth and disagreements within
the political parties so how long are
they going to take are they going to
come up with a format that will be
acceptable to the people I think that
still remains a big question here the
people of course want what they call a
technocratic interim body to rule this
country until there are new elections
under a new non-sectarian electoral law
so these are ambitious demands when
we've been out on the streets today
we've watched the army dismantling the
roadblocks not all protesters were happy
with that some saying that this is
giving into the government before all
their demands have been met others
telling us that no we need to give them
a couple of days we need to give them
two three days to see what's going to
happen what's going to be implemented
this lessens the stress on the roads on
the people trying to move around this
country and then we will wait and see so
nothing has been sold yet for sure I
think the challenges start now there is
a political crisis in this country and
again we know from the past this country
has seen political deadlock without a
government without a prime minister for
a very long time so everything is up in
the air as to what shape any interim
body is going to look like and also how
long it's gonna take to agree on that
and then the big question will the
people be happy no protests so far today
than Stephin life beginning to get back
to normal what about the banks have they
reopened
yes we're seeing a slow trickle back to
normal from what's been pretty much a
paralysis of the last two weeks banks
are not open yet they have announced
that as of tomorrow they're going to
resume normal transactions but they're
not physically going to be open their
doors just yet
we are expecting a statement maybe in
the next couple of hours as to when that
may be universities are slowly saying
that they will be resuming classes
tomorrow including the American
University of Beirut they also have been
closed many professors taking to the
streets with their students in these
calls as I mentioned also the roads now
all open across the country so there is
a sense of somewhat normalcy when you
come to just moving around the city the
fact that there's now more confidence
trying to be instilled that they are
saying the banks are gonna reopen but as
I mentioned this doesn't really solve
the bigger political issues on the table
it doesn't resolve the bigger issues
that the people still demand are they
going to lose momentum certainly the
people we've been speaking to will tell
you know that roadblocks can resume if
they're not happy with what's happening
that things can go back to where they
were but again these are very
unpredictable times I don't think anyone
can really tell you what the next few
days are gonna look like or the next few
weeks are gonna look like we're just
gonna have to wait and see al Jazeera
Stephanie Decker reporting live there
from Beirut Steph many thanks